[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de la
revista de prensa aquí en directo
américa de francia 24 vamos a repasar la
prensa francesa porque porque hoy es el
cara a cara el última la última
oportunidad que tienen los candidatos
hablamos del candidato presidente
enmanuel macrón y también la
ultraderechista marine lepén para
dirigirse a sus electores que van a
dirigir un país que en gane por los
próximos cinco años empezamos por lemon
dice debate macro lepén entre los dos
candidatos un quinquenio de
enfrentamientos y que nos diga entonces
rosa parece más de algo que nos
expliquen mejor dicho este artículo de
lemont hola de nuevo raúl este artículo
del mont se remonta a 2017 cuando tuvo
lugar el primer cara a cara entre estos
dos candidatos y dice que en ese momento
marín le pen perdió totalmente su
credibilidad que se rompió en mil
pedazos pero dice también que en ese
debate se sentaron las bases de la
confrontación entre ambos políticos para
los siguientes cinco años las términos
que serían un poco globalizado ser
representados por emanuel macrón versus
patriotas representados por marine lepén
sin embargo insistimos en que una de las
críticas de manuel macro no ha sido
haber comprado este discurso identitario
de la extrema derecha y continuamos con
liberación que plantea qué temas van a
tratarse en este cara a cara poder
adquisitivo pensiones el velo europa y
los campos de batalla esperados del
debate macro lepén exacto porque digamos
que a cada uno de los candidatos le
interesaba empezar por un tema distinto
mientras aquel open quería que empezara
este cara cara por la cuestión del poder
adquisitivo porque recordemos en esta
campaña de des de abolición de su imagen
como ella lo ha llamado pues se ha
centrado más en esta cuestión económica
que no tanto en las cuestiones
identitarias que la caracterizan
mientras que emanuel macrón aprovechando
su alto perfil en términos diplomáticos
que ha jugado en el marco de la guerra
en ucrania quería empezar por cuestiones
internacionales se ha jugado a suertes
este orden y será el siguiente poder
adquisitivo internacional modelo social
ecología economía educación seguridad y
política interior y destaca liberación
que mientras para el pen el reto es
borrar el mal recuerdo que dejó su
participación en el debate de 2017 y
capitalizar el descontento contra macrón
macrón consciente de eso de que el epen
atacará su balance político de estos 5
años dijo que se tomaba en serio este
cara cara lo que liberación considera un
acto de humildad y vamos ahora a hablar
del director de media par que publicó su
opinión en el medio que dirige está
titulada contra el epp en votar con
dolor para alejar el miedo que se
refiere rosa pues mira está este
artículo de opinión está archivado
dentro de una campaña que hay dentro de
una carpeta que este medio ha dedicado
al siguiente tema marín depende en el
poder el peligro se precisa y han
abordado la cuestión desde muchas
aristas distintas pero precisamente en
este texto de opinión él conoce
periodista edwy plenel y director de
mediapart como decías hace la siguiente
reflexión la extrema derecha nunca había
estado tan cerca del poder y dado que la
extrema derecha es la peor enemiga de la
igualdad de los derechos y de las
libertades votar contra su candidata es
decir votar contra marin de penn es la
sola opción antifascista en el marco
electoral pero matiza este voto contra
el epen será con dolor porque implica
elegir la papeleta con el nombre del
primer responsable de esta catástrofe
emanuel macrón y el medio estructuras y
bounty hablan de los seguidores de
extrema derecha para seguir hablando de
extrema derecha que estábamos hablando
antes rosa exactamente street pres es un
medio que desde hace tiempo sigue muy de
cerca los movimientos de extrema derecha
en francia y un poco la amenaza que
suponen a nivel tanto político como
social y en este caso máximas e hiper
plutus
10 firman un artículo que se llama
antisemitas fascistas identitarios los
radicales con lepén y defienden que si
bien la candidata ha suavizado su
postura en temas como la economía o en
temas como la relación entre francia y
la unión europea su programa continúa
siendo de extrema derecha de hecho ambos
periodistas afirman lo siguiente bajo la
cobertura del azul marino el marrón
nunca ha abandonado totalmente el
partido y el marrón en referencia a las
camisas del uniforme del partido nazi
alemán y también seguimos hablando de
periodistas cerramos esta revista de
prensa rosa con un detalle en este
debate que vamos a ver unas pocas horas
la elección de los periodistas que leo
van a mediar que ha pasado lo que ha
pasado es que cuando se dio por hecho no
los dos candidatos que se iban a
enfrentar en este cara cara de cara a la
segunda vuelta se perfilaba como
moderadora del debate la periodista de
la televisión pública francesa france an
sophie la picks sin embargo ambos
candidatos rechazaron que esta
periodista moderada moderará su
enfrentamiento porque la consideraban
demasiado crítica viena finalmente será
lea salame por la parte de france 2 de
la televisión pública y por otro lado
jill bulo por la parte de tf1 la
principal televisión a francesa pero en
manos privadas los que van a moderar
este debate que recordemos empezará a
las dos de la tarde nuestras horas de
bogotá y lo podrán seguir aquí en
directo y traducido al español no
fundamental para todos ustedes si no hay
crítica no hay prensa rosa eso es
imagínate con qué cara te quedas y te
dicen esto
incluso un halago no claro 100% duda una
un nombre y se les está haciendo un buen
trabajo rosa muchísimas gracias como
siempre nuevos mañana con más de revista
de prensa pasamos a los deportes